[Música]
hay seis heridos en Rusia cerca de la
frontera con Ucrania en ataques que el
kremlin atribuyó a saboteadores de kiev
pero voló culpa a grupos rusos Opuestos
a Putin Tenemos reporte de nuestro
corresponsal en Moscú
el presidente Turco recep erdogan
aumenta su ventaja de cara al balotaje
de este domingo el candidato que quedó
tercero en la primera vuelta
presidencial pidió a sus seguidores el
voto para el actual mandatario que lleva
dos décadas en el poder
el Primer Ministro de Armenia Se declaró
dispuesto a reconocer el enclave del
nagorno carabach como parte de
azerbaiyán a cambio de garantías de
seguridad para la población Armenia de
este territorio que se disputan y ereván
y baku desde hace décadas
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición con información de
la guerra en Ucrania porque el grupo
Wagner aplaza su salida de bacmut Hasta
el 1 de junio esto tras haber asegurado
tener el control total de la ciudad el
pasado sábado una derrota que Ucrania no
reconoce por otro lado este lunes el
campo de batalla volvió a traspasar a
territorio Ruso y es que la región de
vélgorot fronteriza con Ucrania fue
escenario de ataques que han causado
varios heridos la inteligencia militar
ucraniana apunta a la autoría de
milicias rusas antiputín mientras el
kremlin culpa a kiev desde Moscú Xavier
coladas tiene los detalles
Rusia estaba esperando a los ucranianos
al norte de crimea y resulta que han
vuelto a dar la sorpresa unas fuerzas
del lado ucraniano Aparentemente se
trata de voluntarios rusos que luchan
del lado de kiev han penetrado en
territorio ruso en concreto en la región
de velgot una de las pocas partes de
Rusia que ha sido castigada por esta
guerra desde que empezó la invasión en
febrero del año pasado el propio
gobernador de vélgorón de esta región
rusa ha reconocido que se trataba de
unas fuerzas de Sabotaje y
reconocimiento las que habían ingresado
en territorio Ruso y ahora mismo decía
estaban las fuerzas de seguridad rusas
tratando de expulsarlos del territorio o
destruirlos el presidente Vladimir Putin
ha sido informado de lo sucedido y desde
el kremming argumentan que en realidad
se trata de una operación ucraniana de
distracción para esquivar El golpe
político que supone
la pérdida de bajo mundo
cambiamos de información porque en
Turquía se conoció la noticia que tanto
se esperaba para la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones del 28 de mayo finalmente
el candidato ultranacionalista que quedó
en tercer lugar hablamos de sinan ogan
llamó a sus seguidores a apoyar al
actual presidente receptahiperdogán el
líder sinanogan obtuvo el 5% de los
apoyos que serán decisivos en el
balotaje entre erdogan y el opositor
kema el reporte lo tiene desde Estambul
el periodista Albert
el ex candidato a la presidencia sinano
Aunque obtuvo el 5% del apoyo Popular en
las elecciones en Turquía ha dicho esta
misma tarde que va a dar apoyo
en esta segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales aquí en Turquía lo ha
hecho ante una gran expectación por el
significado que pueda tener este 5% de
simpatizantes que la apoyaron y que se
traducen en casi tres millones de votos
que con un perfil
ultranacionalista un discurso
antirefugiados y nunca dispuesto a
pactar con la izquierda curda esta
semana ha realizado varias consultas
para ver a quién apoyaría y finalmente
se ha decantado por erdogan recordemos
que erdogan obtuvo el
49,5% del apoyo popular Mientras que el
opositor que mal kilillo obtuvo el
44,9% es por lo tanto
ahí perdón de en este apoyo por parte
del Tercer candidato de sinano han una
Clara muestra de que este domingo se
puede llegar a imponer en las
presidenciales en Turquía
cambiamos de tema y es que el Primer
Ministro de Armenia Se declaró dispuesto
a reconocer el enclave del nagorno
caravag como parte de azerbaiyán esto a
cambio de que bakú garantice la
seguridad de su población Armenia la
noticia supondría el fin de un conflicto
entre los dos vecinos que se ha
extendido ya por más de tres décadas
Armenia está lista para reconocer la
integridad territorial de azerbaiyán de
86.600 kilómetros cuadrados y en nuestra
opinión azerbaiyán está lista para
reconocer la integridad territorial de
Armenia de 29.800 kilómetros cuadrados
y Grecia se encamina de nuevo a las
urnas a pesar de haber votado ayer
domingo en elecciones generales y es que
la formación conservadora en el poder
nueva democracia ganó los comicios pero
se quedó a las puertas de la mayoría
absoluta y el actual Primer Ministro
quería mitsutakis y ha rechazó la idea
de formar coalición de gobierno y pide
unas nuevas elecciones en que espera que
los resultados le permitan gobernar en
solitario
decidido sonriente solo tiene una idea
en mente organizar nuevas elecciones
legislativas
querías advirtió a la presidenta griega
que no formaría Un gobierno de coalición
tras sus buenos resultados en las
elecciones del domingo
creo que no se dan las condiciones para
la formación de un gobierno con el
actual parlamento
les devuelvo mi mandato para que
celebremos nuevas elecciones lo antes
posible
la decisión viene motivada por una nueva
ley electoral que entra en vigor el mes
que viene un sistema proporciona
reforzado que puede dar hasta 50 escaños
extra al partido líder el domingo la
derecha conservadora de kiriacos ganó
las elecciones por un amplio margen con
el 40.8% de los votos pero se quedó a
las puertas de la mayoría absoluta ya
que obtuvo 146 escaños de los 151 que
necesitaba en el parlamento
Esperamos que Grecia esté mejor en el
futuro porque lo que mixto takis no tuvo
tiempo de hacer en su primer mandato de
4 años lo puede hacer ahora Aunque solo
cumpla la mitad de sus promesas todo irá
bien
en cuanto a la izquierda se ha hundido
el partido sirisa de Alexis cipra solo
obtuvo el 20% de los votos frente al
31.5% de Hace cuatro años
es una gran derrota para la democracia
las instituciones y la sociedad civil
antes de anunciar nuevas elecciones la
presidenta griega tiene primero que dar
mandato a los otros cuatro partidos
representados en el nuevo parlamento es
poco probable que alguno de ellos
consiga formar un gobierno en ese caso
habría que nombrar a un juez de alto
Rango como Primer Ministro interino
y también en Europa la compañía meta
enfrenta una multa histórica y es que la
comisión de protección de datos de
Irlanda sede Europea de las grandes
tecnologías impuso una sanción a la
empresa matriz de Facebook por un total
de
1.300 millones de dólares según el ente
regulador meta ha infringido la
privacidad de sus usuarios a través de
Facebook transfiriendo datos desde la
Unión Europea hacia Estados Unidos Esta
es la sanción económica más alta
impuesta dentro del bloque europeo a una
multinacional
en otras noticias en Sudán hoy entra en
vigor el acuerdo de ces el fuego entre
el ejército sudanés y los paramilitares
alcanzado en Arabia Saudita
negociaciones mediadas por riat y
Washington que a su vez serán los
encargados de supervisar la
implementación de La tregua el informe
es de Max Pérez Gallardo
el acuerdo de lleda crea esperanza en
Sudán a pesar de que los bombardeos del
ejército sudanés en harton continúan el
cese al fuego acordado en la capital
Saudita representa una luz al final del
túnel para muchos udaces La tregua fue
mediada por Arabia Saudita y por Estados
Unidos mismos que se esperan monitoreen
de cerca que tanto el ejército como las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido respeten el alto
a las hostilidades
se trata de un acuerdo muy bueno
realmente Esperamos que se aplique sobre
el terreno y que Estados Unidos y Arabia
Saudita supervisen su aplicación
Esperamos que se consiga seguridad y
estabilidad
Naciones Unidas ha recibido
positivamente el anuncio del acuerdo
Aunque advierte que de no respetarse la
guerra podría escalar y transformar su
naturaleza de un conflicto político aún
no étnico
se han destruido vidas e infraestructura
la crecientenización del conflicto corre
el riesgo de ampliarlo y prolongarlo con
implicaciones para la región el alto el
fuego a corto plazo acordado puede y
debe allanar el camino a las
conversaciones para un cese duradero de
las hostilidades
La tregua temporal duraría una semana
completa y en caso de respetarse sería
el lapso de paz más largo desde que
iniciaron las hostilidades entre ambos
bandos el 15 de abril vamos ahora a
Estados Unidos porque una nueva figura
entra en la carrera presidencial
republicana se trata del senador de
Carolina del Sur Team Scott que lanzó su
candidatura este mismo lunes el político
afro estadounidense Se presenta como una
figura de consensos ante las posturas
radicales tanto del expresidente Donald
Trump como del gobernador rondi santis y
con a 22 millones de dólares Time Scott
es la persona con más dinero en la
cuenta bancaria en lanzarse a la carrera
presidencial en la historia de Estados
Unidos
vamos a España porque el Real Madrid ha
presentado una denuncia por delito de
odio después de que a su delantero
estrella vinicius Junior volviera a ser
víctima de insultos racistas durante un
partido este domingo el presidente de la
liga sin embargo optó por criticar al
jugador
la indignación por el racismo en el
fútbol español ha llegado a nuevos
niveles con el presidente Brasil
condenando los continuos abusos a la
estrella del Real Madrid vinicios Junior
y el presidente de la federación
española de fútbol diciendo que España
tiene un grave problema
tenemos un problema en nuestro país
de comportamiento de educación de
racismo en un partido de visita un
aficionado del Valencia le habría
llamado mono al delantero brasileño el
juego se reanudó 10 minutos después de
un anuncio en el que se pedía que
cesaran los insultos racistas el Real
Madrid ha presentado una denuncia
judicial y vinicius ha emitido un
comunicado en el que afirma que un
campeonato que antes pertenecía a
grandes jugadores ahora pertenece a
racistas el presidente de la liga Javier
tebas respondió que vinicius tenía que
informarse bien quejándose de que el
futbolista no se había presentado a dos
reuniones sobre lo que están haciendo
para combatir el racismo pero el
entrenador del Real Madrid Carlo
ancelotti coincide con su jugador la
liga no está haciendo lo suficiente para
pensar de quitar un jugador para racismo
nunca me ha pasado la
liga española tiene un problema
que no es bien hechos problema bien
hechos es la víctima de un problema muy
grave la liga ha presentado denuncias
ante las autoridades españolas por el
constante abuso racial que sufre
vinicius Mientras tanto la policía
española Investiga un delito de odio
después de que aficionados del club
rival en el Atlético de Madrid colgarán
un muñeco de vinicius frente al campo de
entrenamiento del Real Madrid
y cerramos con ciclismo porque el rey
británico del Sprint Mark cavendish
anunció que pondrá fin a su carrera de
17 años como ciclista profesional al
final de esta temporada durante su
exitosa trayectoria cavendi se acumuló
161 victorias incluidas 34 en el Tour de
Francia también ganó el título mundial
en ruta en 2011 además consiguió una
medalla de plata individual en pista en
los Juegos Olímpicos de Río 2016 así
como tres títulos mundiales en la
disciplina de Madison
hasta aquí las noticias Muchísimas
gracias por su atención
[Música]